we all right
i don't want to ruin my makeup
you might think you know everything
there is to know about kim kardashian
but the reality star spilled the
freaking tea with david letterman
on netflix's my next guest needs no
introduction
i'm so happy that it's been well
received now we are breaking down the
eight things we learned from her tell
all interview starting with this the o.j
simpson trial tore her family apart and
put kim and her sister courtney
in an awkward position the week before
that happened we were all in mexico
together and at a family
trip the simpsons and us chris was best
friends with oj's late wife
nicole brown simpson and took a firm
stand against the former athlete
my mom was extremely vocal on her
feelings
what did she think you know she was
believed that
you know her friend was murdered by him
and that was really traumatizing for her
and then we'd go to my dad's house and
it was a whole other situation there and
it would be like johnny cochran bob
shapiro
my dad like the whole team so we didn't
really know what to believe or whose
side to take as kids
because we didn't want to hurt one of
our parents feelings
kim says the tension only got worse as
the trial continued
my dad took us to court one day with him
and he took us out of school and didn't
tell my mom
and i remember my mom was sitting with
nicole's parents and
courtney and i were sitting right behind
o.j
and we like look over at my mom and
she's like giving us this death stare
like what are you doing out of school
what are you doing here
and courtney and i were like just look
straight do not look at mom
it kind of tore our family apart i'd say
for the whole time of the trial and
speaking of awkward number seven on our
list kim was once mistakenly mislabeled
as
a mistress arriving at her dad's house
yup kim recalls after oj was deemed
not guilty in court robert told a then
14 year old kim and her sister courtney
to come to the house where the legal
team was celebrating
well the two drove over illegally and
were snapped entering the house
i pulled up to the gate on my way home
and there was all these cameras outside
and then that night on hard copy
it said robert kardashian's mistress
pulling up to his house
and i was like oh my god like i couldn't
believe it
that they were making this stuff up and
that was like my first real lesson with
the media
moving right along to number six kim's
following in her late dad's footsteps
studying law and when it comes to her
non-traditional law program
the 40 year old is in good company
abraham lincoln did it this way
famously so it's it's legit the kkw
founder assured people that her at home
program through the california state bar
is just as hard as the more traditional
law school route
and get ready for the cutest thing
you'll hear all day
kim's hubby kanye west helps their
daughter north with her school
dance competitions we just took our
daughter to a
a school dance and there's a dance
competition
and you know how will she feel if she
wins how she feels she doesn't win
and it consumes you so how did she do at
the dance competition
her and kanye have won i think the last
two years in a row
she definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend
and get this none of us have spoken
and we're letting bruce speak first
before caitlyn jenner fully transitioned
kim recalls being 26 years old and
walking in on her then step dad bruce
dressed as a woman bruce called my phone
and said whenever you're ready i'd love
to sit you down and talk to you
but in the meantime don't tell a soul
your mom has no idea and she will kill
me
it was just a little confusing because
we all wanted to be there in support of
but then also wanting to support our mom
who this is news to
married to someone for 22 years her
heart is broken
and they have children and and it was
just a lot
when you kind of find out along with the
whole world
but my favorite moment of the whole
thing kim
admitting her little sisters kendall and
kylie jenner
have no clue who david letterman is
yes i'm serious i hope hope hope
you don't take offense to this but i was
telling kendall and kylie i was like
oh i'm gonna go do letterman and they
were like who what
like like like they
literally only do social media stuff
and that to me was like what it was so
fascinating
number two on our list kim revealed that
back in october 2016
on the same day she was robbed at
gunpoint in paris
she had a conversation earlier that day
about a potential robbery scenario
me and my girlfriends we had lunch that
day
and said if you guys were robbed what
would you do would you just give them
the stuff
why we had this conversation it was so
wild and i said i would say
take everything just take just take
everything nothing is important
and last but not least kim
thinks her man makes more money than her
keyword being
thinks who's making more money
him probably probably probably how close
are we
we're exactly even
[Laughter]
well good we both are really blessed and
do extremely well
and i'm really grateful